When we do a one-tailed test, the p value is the probability above the t
statistic if it's positive, and below the t statistic if it's negative. But for
a two-tailed test, the p value is both the probability above that t statistic
And the probablity less than the negative value of that T statistic. If we had
gotten a negative T statistic to begin with it'd be the same thing. The T value
would be the sum of the probablity below that T statistic and above the
positive value of that T statistic. We reject the null, when the p-value is
less than the alpha level. Let's say we have the following sample. Is this
sample mean significantly different from 10 at an alpha level of 0.5? First,
calculate the t-statistic. Remember to use the sample standard deviation for s.